a musical called bedbugs
that's right bedbugs just ended a
successful run off-broadway yes this is
we operably musical got bedbugs it's a
real thing it's a musical about New York
serious bedbug infestation they made a
musical about that well out here and no
no everyone else was right not to clap
here's to musical yeah oh but here in
Southern California of course we don't
have a bedbug epidemic but we do have
another serious
animal nuisance that terrorizes
homeowners in Southern California and
it's been turned into a musical that's
already been previewed here in Los
Angeles
we're gonna show you a bit of it tonight
this is a real treat ladies and
gentlemen I give you the musical bears
in our pool Peter takes a dip in a
backyard pool Tuesday morning in the
Sierra Madre foothills but they know to
keep a distance and trash locked up will
you look at that could that happen here
daddy of course not honey that's way up
in the hills besides we have a fence dad
you might want to take a look at this
call animal control
[Music]
halt quick honey
lock the doors we've got to keep our
children from the scary carnivores we've
got to keep my children from the scary
carnivores Simeone there's no need to be
frightened they don't mean any harm they
just came here to cool off coz the
weather got too warm
there's your pool we frolic in our water
when temperatures get mired there's air
a pool you don't need to run away
they're just like giant puppies and mayo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you